hello everyone it is Friday
a little after 3 p.m. and you know what
that means it's time for our live
version of your daily equation in which
in the live version we talk about
equations but basically anything else
that you feel like talking about most of
the time we do talk about science
quantum mechanics relativity Einstein's
string theory unified theories and so
forth yeah as funny as I say there and I
realize that we never talk about what's
happening in the world maybe you're
tired of hearing all about that and
seeing it all on the news but man oh man
what an insane period of time we are
living through in the United States and
all I can say to the rest of the world
is I'm sorry there's nothing more that
can be said what a disgraceful situation
we have in this country right now so
anybody want to talk about that I'm
happy to but let's go to the rarified
beautiful pristine elegant realm of math
physics and the universe just to have a
little bit of mental rest bite from
everything that's happening in the world
so I'm gonna jump right in to some
questions and let's see what will I
begin with
well Andrew Hanny asks when was the
first time that the fourth dimension was
introduced and what was the scientific
motivation for that and I understand
exactly what you're asking
Andrew when was the fourth dimension
introduced as an idea in physics I think
is really what you have in mind there
I'm guessing that's what you have in
mind but mathematically people were
thinking about shapes and spaces that
could exist in any number of dimensions
long before and you know what
mathematicians do they they write down
the equations to describe things that
you can first visualize and see and then
they're motivated by the language of
mathematics to generalize the insights
that they have in the ordinary three
dimensions that you can see to higher
dimension so Riemann who really wasn't
thinking about physics applications
that's not completely sure Riemann did
have some of his thinking oriented by
physics but to first approximation for
non physics reasons Riemann and others
began to think about higher dimensional
geometrical shapes how do you describe
the curvature of a higher dimensional
geometric shape how do you scribe
distances on a higher dimensional
geometric shape and so the fourth
dimension was introduced way back in
physics it really came to light through
we often think Einstein but it was
really Hermann Minkowski Hermann
Minkowski was Einstein's teacher
Einstein's professor famously called him
a lazy dog thought that Einstein was not
going to really achieve anything with
his life at least not in science but man
was he wrong has perhaps the worst
prediction in the history of being a
professor my goodness
makes us all feel a little bit better
but Minkowski did have the great insight
when Sein Stein put forward the special
theory of relativity was Minkowski who
said we
really think about space and time
unified together three dimensions of
space and one dimension of time and the
reason it came to that realization is
because Einsteins insights showed that
motion through space affects your
passage through time let me say that
again because that is a deep
mind-blowing sentence motion through
space affects your passage through time
nobody thought that before according to
Newton you can move through space any
which way and the temporal quality the
time it just elapses the way that it
always would Einstein said that's not
true if you move through space then
someone who's watching you will note
that your clock is ticking off time more
slowly than it was when you were
stationary motion through space slowed
your passage through time so Minkowski
says we now have a deep connection
unexpected deep connection between space
and time let's knit them together into a
four-dimensional structure called
space-time and within that rubric the
equations that Einstein gave us have the
most elegant and economical formulation
so that's where it happened in physics
and that's the scientific motivation for
that let me go over I saw some question
that I'd liked him
oh yeah well here's a so Jessica from
Wichita asks when you talk about the
equations of the universe are you
referring to equations that are somehow
out there part of the universe or are
you describing something that we humans
make up to describe the universe so yeah
it's a very deep question is math a
description of the world or is math part
of the world and by world I mean reality
and I don't know the answer to that
question nobody knows the answer to that
question in the course of my own career
in my perspective on that has shifted a
number of times there have been
occasions where you just sort of feel
that the math is out there and all
you're doing is revealing
and for I'm Stein of course you're
revealing a masterpiece sort of like the
way sometimes people describe the
sculptures that are created by the great
se Renaissance sculptors as being
embedded in the marble and although
sculptor is doing is chipping away the
excess material to reveal this
masterwork embedded within the marble or
is it that the marble just has no
internal fundamental structure and it
really is the artist who is sculpting
out of that chaos if you will something
of great beauty and great order so it's
kind of analogous to that question my
view now and it's been this way for a
while so maybe I'm done waffling back
and forth on the issue my view now is
that math is a language it is a language
of human invention it's a language
that's particularly good at articulating
patterns and because the world happens
to abide by patterns I'm talking about
the patterns abstractly that two plus
two equals four or the pattern of the
moon going around the earth at a certain
regular rate or the earth going around
the Sun at a regular rate or when you
throw a ball through the air it goes in
a shape that is repeated over and over
again when you throw the ball over and
over again these kind of patterns are
right for articulation right for
description in the language of
mathematics and that's what we do as
physicists try to find those equations
that describe those patterns so I would
put it that way as of today I would say
that's not that the math is actually out
there it's the language that we invent
to describe what is out there and I
should say that question brings to mind
what a question that hasn't been asked
right here but it's very similar to that
question which is am i inconsistent and
someone has called me on this am i
inconsistent in my description of the
universe because often times I will
speak as though the laws of Einstein's
general relativity laws as Schrodinger
quantum mechanics laws of Newton
some mechanical I often describe it as
if those laws govern the universe as if
they are somehow there and they are
enforcing the mathematical description
and if they're there enforcing it and
they are transcending human presence if
the laws are governing the worlds not we
humans are governing the world then
haven't I now said something
inconsistent on the one hand I'm saying
the mathematics is a human invention at
the other hand I'm saying that the math
is governing the universe and I'm not
trying to say that we humans are
governing the universe so what in the
world am I going on about well it's
often just a softness of language that I
think most of us understand if I was
being really precise here's what I would
say and if ever I say something in these
sessions or others that feel
inconsistent on this point come back to
this description my view is there are
laws there are laws out there that
transcend human presence I don't know
the right language for describing those
laws as of today the best language that
we have is mathematics and therefore we
use mathematics to articulate the laws
of general relativity and quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics and so
forth but that's a description the laws
are out there the laws do govern the
laws are controlling in the sense that
the processes of the universe don't step
outside of those laws not can I prove
that I can't what do we do we look at
the enormous mountain of data
accumulated in some sense since the
beginning of human civilization and we
have never found repeatable examples in
the world in which the patterns were
violated sometimes we didn't understand
the patterns and we needed very
intelligent individuals to come along
and give us a deeper understanding of
what their patterns are and they phrase
those insights in the language of
mathematics but to my mind those
mathematical sentences are approaching
an explanation and understanding of the
laws that are out there
but I'm not saying that the laws
themselves are necessarily framed in the
language of mathematics maybe they are
maybe they're not so from that
perspective it's consistent to say that
mathematics is human invention that
language to describe the patterns the
patterns described by laws are out there
what's the real fundamental way of
describing those patterns I don't know
maybe it is math maybe it is not on that
we do not have an answer okay what else
do we have so a seat - asked what are
the future goals of CERN's Large Hadron
Collider which is an important question
to ask a lot of money was put into the
collider and the primary initial goal
was to find the Higgs particle the Higgs
boson this little packet of the Higgs
field which Peter Higgs conjectured
surmised would be a field uniformly
filling space that would exert a kind of
molasses like tug on any particle moving
through the universe and that molasses
like tug would be the origin of the mass
of each and every particle so there was
a big puzzle before Higgs came along
which is how do fundamental particles
acquire mass because the mathematics
seemed to suggest that all particles
should be massless the mathematics
relies on certain deep symmetry
principles and the symmetry principles
seem to demand that the particles were
massless and Higgs is resolutions this
was he said look the particles are
massless fundamentally from the get-go
but once those particles are moving
through space they acquire mass through
an interaction with the environment not
because they intrinsically have heft per
se but rather because they're
interacting with the quality of the
environment as the particles move they
are like little pebbles trying to make
their way through molasses and just as
the pebble will feel a drag force from
the molasses particles feel a drag force
from the Higgs field how do you try to
prove this crazy sounding idea
well the theory that Higgs put forward
also shows that you should be able to
slam space by having particles collide
at high energy and when you slam in some
sense empty space it can cause the Higgs
field to jiggle and if you jiggle it in
the right way little particle sprays
will fly off the higgs field sort of
like if you slap the surface of water
droplets of water will spray outward and
the droplets of the Higgs field that
would spray outward would be Higgs
particles so the Large Hadron Collider
was built to try to find those Higgs
particles and as everybody here I hope
knows that was an incredibly remarkably
successful undertaking 2012 we found the
particle okay good so the question then
is what's next now what we hoped would
be next would be the detection of
so-called supersymmetric particles these
are particles put forward by a different
theory a theory called supersymmetry
whose development goes way back to the
early 70s it's a another type of
symmetry first discovered actually by
people studying string theory just
saying it was then generalized to other
areas of particle physics that don't
have to have strings in them at all but
it's a very general phenomenon that for
every known particle that we have so far
detected supersymmetry requires that
there's a partner particle so for
electrons you should have select ron's
for quarks squarks neutrinos neutrinos
don't look at me like that I don't make
up the names all right I just follow the
conventions and so the hope was that the
Large Hadron Collider would find these
partner particles to the known particles
and that was the next goal and the fact
of the matter is we've been at it for
some time and none of the supersymmetric
particles have been found and that's
kind of sad at some level for many of us
but I mean nature
not constructed to make physicists happy
that's something that steven weinberg
has emphasized to us repeatedly but yeah
it would have been nice to find those
particles we still may if I look back at
my own career I would say that 90% of
the papers that I've written in one way
or another touch on supersymmetry so how
sad would it be if if this quality in
the mathematics is not realized in the
real world thankfully some of my papers
are just in the mathematical side of
things so whether or not the particles
are real the mathematical insights
derived from the symmetry they're
unassailable but yeah it would be great
to find the supersymmetric particles
circumstantial evidence even for string
theory so my hope is I see that that's
what will be next but the window of
opportunity is shrinking and shrinking
so I wouldn't hold your breath on that
one and then after that we may need
really to upgrade the Large Hadron
Collider to a machine that has greater
energy reach China is talking about the
possibility of building the next
detector the next accelerator with
detectors of course and that may be ten
twenty years into the future so it could
be that in the worst of all
circumstances particle physics may at
least at the level of the energy scales
that we hope to probe ever higher and
ever smaller length scales that may go
into a hiatus in the not-too-distant
future as we wait for a machine that can
really take the leap to ever higher
energies so I don't know the answer but
that is certainly one possibility
perhaps that's the the least happy one
but look we can still find the
supersymmetric particles we could still
find unexpected things in fact that's
probably the best answer to your
question I see what's next
I don't know but I hope it's a big
surprise we live for the unexpected
results that forced us to go back and
rethink our theories so that that may be
hopefully what happens next
Yash Shah asks can general theory of
relativity be questioned on the basis of
Hawking radiation and the answer
yosh is absolutely not absolutely not so
Einstein's general theory of relativity
is a classical theory it is a theory
that doesn't know about the quantum
nature of the world
Einstein developed the general theory of
relativity in you know 1907 to 1915
those were the years in which a parallel
track was developing quantum mechanics
but Einstein wasn't waiting for quantum
mechanics to be completed before he dove
in to try to come up with a new
description of the force of gravity so
Einstein's theory doesn't talk to
quantum mechanics from the get-go and
Hawking radiation emerges only when you
meld certain aspects of quantum
mechanics with the general theory of
relativity
so it's not that Hawking radiation
contradicts Einstein's theory Hawking
radiation is a natural outcome of
extending the general theory of
relativity to include certain quantum
mechanical qualities so in that sense
they are naturally linked together in a
progression from the classical
description to the description that goes
one or two steps further to bringing
quantum mechanics in to the story
okay hello professor greens
Sami Saeed asks if we go into space and
rotate in the opposite direction of
Earth's rotation and twice the speed
isn't that time-traveling so so the
answer to that question is yes and no I
kind of think from the framing of the
question Sami that what you have in mind
is that scene from Superman where
Superman kind of circles around the
earth really quickly in the opposite
direction to the Earth's rotation and
somehow goes backward in time and I
think the intuition there is that if the
earth is turning this way and time is
going forward then if time was going
back where the earth would kind of go
the opposite direction or at least if we
go the opposite direction we're going
backward in time and none of that none
of that holds any any real water the
orientation of the spin of the earth
whether viewed saved from the North Pole
down is counterclockwise or clockwise is
not what determines the arrow of time
from the past toward the future instead
the arrow of time from the past toward
the future as you can see in your daily
equation maybe it's the last episode
that I did the things I think it was
number 32 or something that comes from
considerations of entropy second law of
thermodynamics the Big Bang being a
highly ordered state and so forth and
those qualities of the world are not
dependent upon the very specific
orientation of the Earth's spin now
there is a way of interpreting your
question which does yield a more
positive result which is whenever you go
into motion your clock will slow down
relative to my clocks if I'm looking at
you in motion then your clock is going
slow so if you then return toward me
undergoing some round-trip journey some
accelerated trajectory to return to the
starting point you will have not
traveled into the past you'll have
travelled into the future
because my watch will have ticked off
more time than yours and by my watch I
mean everything about me
itself will have elapsed in a greater
duration during your journey so you will
have jumped into a later time period and
so there is a kind of time travel that
comes from precisely what you described
that kind of motion but it's not time
traveling toward the past although you
didn't actually say toward the past so
maybe that's what you have had in mind
it's time traveling toward the future so
Sami if I misunderstood your question
you should come back at me I'm happy to
revisit it if I didn't interpret your
question correctly Paul C asks with
eight stars and therefore definitely
requires me to answer hi professor
Greene how was the Big Bang low or even
zero entropy and the quickest answer is
I don't know
yeah I'll go a little further than that
can't help it so we make an assumption
that the Big Bang was highly ordered low
entropy why do we make that assumption
we make that assumption because it's the
only way that we can articulate it's not
the only way but to my mind is the most
convincing way that we have ever come to
for articulating why there is a
direction to time right so we all know
that there are these qualities of the
world that are asymmetric in time
various things right we age we don't
UNAIDS and you guys maybe it's not you
guys explicitly there are many people on
my videos who remind me that I am ageing
I really do appreciate that so I love it
when you guys tell me how old I've
gotten so thank you I really I really do
enjoy that but yeah that's you're just
reminding me of this important physical
fact that time has a direction to it it
goes from the past toward the future but
even more mundane things they become
hackneyed after a while but you know
glasses shatter they don't uncheck
splatter they don't unsplit a candles
burn and they don't unburned right a
gazillion things that have a temporal
orientation to them why in the world do
they have that temporal orientation and
if you look at the laws of physics
themselves as I emphasized in episode 32
the laws treat past and future an equal
footing so you can't just appeal to the
laws and say the laws don't allow
glasses to unshadowed people to on age
now the laws and principle do allow that
to happen then what do you do well this
is what took us to this idea of entropy
that there is a natural tendency simply
by the law of large numbers for systems
to go from order to disorder because to
be disordered is a very easy
configuration to achieve there are so
many ways to be disordered an order
situation well that's highly organized
that's hard
that requires everything to be in its
proper place and therefore it's very
difficult compared ly speaking to be
ordered
and so as particles are randomly moving
around of course they're gonna move
toward disorder because it's so much
easier there's so many more ways to be
disorder than ordered but that only
really holds any water if there was a
state of order to begin with if you have
a state of disorder at the start at the
Big Bang then you'd have disorder all
the time you need order in order to
anchor the hour of time so that as time
unfolds from the Big Bang you are
creeping up toward ever greater disorder
but along the way and route today you
still have some residual order that's
why we make this assumption now can we
explain the order of the Big Bang I've
tried everything papers on this none of
them really are convincing because
oftentimes you find that you're sneaking
in an assumption of order in a different
language or a different mathematical
formalism so I would say that today
there are some people who say it's not a
question that even is worth asking
because they say look you know we have
one universe when people say that the
Big Bang was highly ordered and
therefore that's very unlikely because
ordered states are very unlikely they're
basing that on intuition from everyday
life yeah it is unlikely that if I take
a hundred pennies and I throw them on
the floor they will land in the order
state of all heads if very unlikely if I
throw those pennies it's far more likely
that the land were roughly 50 heads and
50 tails because there are so many ways
in which you can get 50 heads and 50
tails
someone told me how to pronounce that
number maybe is on your daily equation a
hundred octillion someone told me is how
you pronounce that number so it's you
know much more easy but that's in
everyday life with pennies or other
familiar structures when it comes to the
universe what do you mean when you say
that it was unlikely for the Big Bang to
be ordered did you have many big bangs
and you look at all of them and you
found that the preponderance of examples
had high disorder and very few had high
order is that the sense do you imagine
that you're throwing darts
at possible universes from a range of
possibilities and for your dart to hit
the universe that has an ordered Big
Bang is just unlikely because there's so
many more universes that have a
disordered Big Bang what do you mean by
unlikely in the most straightforward
interpretation you can say look if
there's one universe you can say if
these ideas are correct that it began
ordered with 100% certainty it was
ordered and there's only one universe
period that's it so you have to be
careful when you generalize from
unlikely events in everyday life to
unlikely events when it comes to the
universe as a whole so look if we could
find an explanation that really gave us
some insight into a process that
required or insured or entail that the
universe was highly ordered at the Big
Bang we'd all be happy
we'd all feel like we'd made progress
but if you don't have that explanation
it may simply be telling us that we're
asking the wrong question that the
orderly state of the Big Bang may have
been an environmental state that we just
need to accept as is because the
universe happened once and for whatever
reasons for whatever reason there is
something rather than nothing that
something came into existence in an
orderly state that could however
unsatisfying that could be the answer
sir view Muntean hi professor O'Brien
can you explain how Einstein theory of
gravity applies to us or objects sitting
on the surface of the earth yeah I can't
I can so the imagery that we often use
in the general theory of relativity is
say you have a star and the presence of
the star warps the environment around us
we often give a 2-dimensional image for
that which is not perfect by any means
but you have say the Sun and you have
this warped shape underneath it now
there is no underneath the Sun what's
really happening it's warped all around
and so forth but let's use that imagery
just to have something to hang my answer
on visually the earth does the same
thing to the environment and
means is our bodies want to slide down
that indentation in space-time but what
happens is the surface of the earth gets
in our way like right now my body wants
to slide downward but my body is hitting
this chair and this chair has legs that
are hitting the floor and the floor is
hitting the surface of the earth the
earth is getting in the way so you can
think about it as if there's a slide
that in the absence of the Earth's
surface if the earth surface they were
compressed so it was a hundred miles
closer to the center of the earth my
body would want to slide all the way
along that from where I currently am but
because the Earth's surface is there my
body slams into it so the upward force
that you feel right now that I feel
right now from whatever structure is
supporting us that upward push is
happening because general tivity is
trying to guide our bodies along the
indentations in the space-time fabric
that the earth creates but this surface
of the earth is getting in the way
that's certainly one way of thinking
about it now as a caveat I'll note to
you that near the surface of the earth
the better description is not really
that space is warped it's actually that
time is warped I haven't actually
discussed this in a your daily equation
yet but I kind of should because it's a
beautiful idea and it's one that doesn't
get as much play as it might but when
you try to understand ordinary gravity
that we experienced from Einstein's
general theory of relativity it's the
temporal part of the distortion that
really captures the kind of gravity the
relatively weak gravity that we all feel
and so in some sense what Einstein tells
us is that time elapsed is slower and
slower and slower toward the surface of
the earth or toward the source of
gravity more generally and objects
according to Einstein are drawn toward
those locations where time elapses more
slowly
so rather than thinking in the spatial
example which is a fine way so I'm not
trying to undermine my own answer here
but in the spatial example I had our
bodies trying to slide along an
indentation as if it was a slide in a in
a in a children's park or water slide in
in a play world type of environment but
a better description is that we're
trying to move toward the direction
where time elapses more slowly so maybe
the cosmetics industry is a better
metaphor or a cosmetics industry we
spend billions of dollars trying to look
as though time is elapsing more slowly
Einstein's theory fits in with that urge
because the geodesics in a spacetime
environment point in the direction of
the slowing of time that's actually what
happens in the general theory of
relativity and as you say that I'm gonna
have to keep them back in mind I realize
I've never given the geodesic equation
in general relativity I don't think I've
given you the equation D 2 X mu D tau
squared plus gamma mu nu lambda DX nu D
tau D X lambda D tau equal to 0 or
gammas the Christoffel connection good I
got our equation and I'm happy now so
that equation till tells you the
shortest possible trajectory in a
spacetime environment with a connection
gamma determined by a metric G and what
I just described is what happens in the
vicinity of a body that doesn't have a
fantastically strong gravitational field
and a body that's not moving
relativistically so that is the answer
to your question
dang JA says that should be our next day
of the equation dang I agree with them
just not sure when exactly that will be
so captain Benzino is a long question so
I'm taking a risk on you captain Benzino
I'm gonna read it without knowing
whether it's a question that I want to
address but here we go
maybe dipping into science fiction here
oh I'm setting to worry but black holes
all right now I'm feeling a little bit
better must hold infinite mysteries
is it theoretically possible to create a
material or substance with elastic
properties to probe and send a signal so
I think what you have in mind there is
kind of unfurling some kind of object
maybe like a big piece of rope or a
bungee cord that could be rolled out
from a safe distance from a black hole
toward a black hole in order to probe
its properties and captain BZ no I don't
know if that's ever going to be
practical in the real world probably it
will be if life persists long enough in
fact there's something called the
Penrose process that Roger Penrose real
iconic figure in in math and physics and
by the way I'm not I'm gonna answer
captain ben zena's question but I'm just
just comes to mind I was thinking that
it might be fun in some of these are
daily equations if I bring in some of my
colleagues that you maybe read their
books or read their their ideas to sort
of have an informal conversation of
their favorite equations and some of the
insights into the world that are due to
them so if you would be interested in me
doing that on occasion as opposed to me
just talking to you straight out let me
know I'd be happy to do that but but the
Penrose process is one in which in
principle if you have a rotating black
hole and you can somehow lower down a
bucket toward the black hole you can in
some sense scoop out energy from the
black hole through this process so
people have thought about this idea at
least hypothetically Captain Beenzino
moreover when you try to understand the
entropy of black holes the disorder of
black holes one of the ways of doing
that is you imagine
lowering one bit of entropy into a black
hole and you ask yourself what happens
when the black hole absorbs that
disorder but happens is the event
horizon grows by a minimal amount a
Planck area divided by four which is all
just to say that even though you thought
of this in a kind of science fictiony
way we physicists often make use of
thought experiments
today that invoked the very kind of
setup that you envision lowering things
into a black hole so the answer is yes
very much so
at least from a theoretical standpoint
it's been very useful to think that way
practically I don't know we'll uh we'll
have to wait and see how things evolve
toward the future okay what do we have
oh there's a 0.99 question maybe I'll
come back to that if but let's see
so Leandro scheppers asks hello
professor green what happens to the
energy of a photon that gets red shifted
by the universe that is expanding and
and that's a that's absolutely a
justifiable question you know we often
say that when you have a photon in
expanding environment what happens is
that the photon itself is somehow
sufficiently woven into the threads of
space-time that as the fabric expands
the photon itself gets kind of pulled
outward like an accordion and that
stretching of its wavelength it lowers
its energy makes it head more toward the
red part of the spectrum assuming that
was on the other side of red redshifting
can be an increase in energy if you're
on the other side but if you're on the
higher energy side of red then the red
shifting takes you to the lower energy
so where does the energy go when that
happens and the answer is that it goes
into the gravitational potential energy
you have to remember what happens when a
baseball is thrown upward there's a
baseballs thrown upward to go slower and
slower where does the energy go
it goes into gravitational potential
energy because the baseballs fighting
against gravity in some sense and
gravity is also what's responsible for
the expansion of space so in some sense
the stretching of the photon is going
into a kind of gravitational potential
as well so that's the answer to the red
shifting energy of a photon and
expanding universe okay
see hackers lab hi professor what do we
mean by a tear in space and how does
strength Eve explain these and then
repair the tear in space-time always a
fun question for me to address as III
think hackers lab knew that I would be
open to the question since I was the
person with a cup of college who wrote
the first papers on these ideas but so a
tear in the fabric of space what does
that mean well literally what we mean
not literally what we mean is I hate
hate when people use the word literally
wrong what we mean is there are shapes
that cannot be smoothly deformed one
into another there are other shapes that
you can smoothly deform one into another
for instance if you gave me a beach ball
and it was made up of elastic material I
could smoothly stretch the beads fall
and turn it into more like an egg shape
so the beach ball in the egg shape are
what we say they have the same topology
they have shapes that can be smoothly
deformed continuously is probably a
better word from one into another there
are other shapes where there is no such
continuous motion of that for instance
if I give you a doughnut and a ball to
turn the ball into a doughnut you've got
to somehow rip an opening inside there's
no way that you can continuous deform
one into another and so when we say that
space tears what we really mean is the
topology the shape of space is changing
in a manner that cannot be accomplished
through a continuous process so have in
mind going from doughnut to ball our
ball - doughnut you've got a tear or
you've got a rip open the shape be going
from doughnut to ball you've got to kind
of cut along one of the circular parts
around the the center of the
donut and then you can turn it into like
a banana shape and then you can reshape
that into a sphere so what we found is
in string theory the universe can evolve
continuously smoothly between two
different shapes that are topologically
distinct shapes that cannot be smoothly
continuously transformed into one
another and string theory protects us
from what otherwise would have been a
disastrous consequence inside the
general theory of relativity where the
space cannot tear and that's really what
we mean by the fabric space ripping and
what we mean by strength you're allowing
these processes to happen Alice says
that she's getting hungry I guess that
was my reference to Donuts you know
Alice I'm kind of hungry too I'm
wondering you know if we did these
sessions long enough we should set it up
in such a way that everybody gets dinner
delivered regardless of where you are in
the world that would be kind of we will
do that no doubt one day not yet but I
am tempted to bring my dinner to these
sessions as they seem to go longer week
after week Niraj ask professor does the
size of a black hole increase as it eats
space-time there's a culinary theme that
we see threaded through a number of
these questions now so we're back to
questions of imbibing food so does the
size of a black hole increase as it eats
space-time well I don't know exactly
precisely what you mean by eating
space-time but I would say that when the
black hole eats material objects if you
throw those doughnuts into a black hole
the doughnuts have mass they've energy
and as the black hole absorbs the energy
the black hole grows in size because
remember that the radius of a black hole
and by radius I'm there's a precise
meaning but roughly speaking you can
think of it as the size of the black
hole it's related to the surface area of
its event horizon but the the radius of
a black hole is proportional to its mass
right R equals to GM over C squared
that's the formula for the radius of a
black hole of mass
where G is Newton's constant and C is
the speed of light so if the mass goes
up the radius goes up so as the black
hole eats stuff that increases its mass
its size does increase I'm not exactly
sure what you mean by eating space time
I've seen you have a second part of the
question can it be used to test a
spacetime as made of particles so you
really do mean the eating of space
itself and I'm trying to think how to
interpret that I'm not exactly sure how
to interpret that statement it is the
case that according to Stephen Hawking
the reverse happens that a black hole
can have particles radiated toward
infinity that's kind of the reverse of
eating I don't want to get into the kind
of gross description that is running
through my head right now and the
concept of reverse eating is brought to
bear so I will exercise restraint and I
don't know if my my wife is listening to
this but I hope that you're proud of me
for not saying what crossed my mind a
moment to go but as the radiation comes
out of a black hole the black hole is
emitting energy emitting food if you
will and because of that it's size gets
smaller and smaller so it's kind of the
reverse of what you're talking about
the black hole is giving back space-time
because now you have more and more space
outside the event horizon of a black
hole and as it's giving back that space
the way it does so is it's emitting
particles toward infinity so you kind of
see the interplay between the size of a
black hole the amount of space outside
of it and the radiation that it's
emitting so I hope that approaches an
answer to the question that you have
again come back if somehow that does not
satisfy you pry out
that's what is mirror symmetry and I
think you guys conspired today and said
let's ask let's ask Brian crane all the
questions about this stuff that he did
so he'll he'll feel good today so thank
you for that I do it does feel good for
you to ask about the stuff that I've
been involved in so mirror symmetry is a
property that I found with my colleague
Ronan Plesser who is now at Duke this
was in the late 1980s and I should say
there was a another group that found
effectively the same idea from a very
different perspective that was led by my
colleague and friend Phillip Ken Delos
is now at Oxford and various of his
students trying to remember it's been a
long time Monica linker Rolf shimmer ik
I believe are on the initial paper that
they wrote back then and and the insight
that we found is that when you're
looking at the extra dimensions in
string theory so in the most
conventional formulation of strength
there there are six extra dimensions
note to self
I should do your daily equation on extra
dimensions I think I will do that but
you have these six extra dimensions in
string theory and what we found is the
shapes of those extra dimensions come in
pairs that look completely different
technically they're topologically
distinct they're completely different
geometrically topologically and yet they
give rise to exactly the same physical
properties in a universe in which they
are taken to be the extra dimensions and
that's highly unexpected because in the
general theory of relativity even if you
don't understand the mathematical
details what we have been describing
over the course of your daily equation
but even here today is the geometrical
shape of space-time dictates the
physical processes that ensue right if
you've got a shape like this then the
shortest trajectories which are the
geodesics that particles will follow
will be different
from a shape which is radically
different from the initial shape but
surprisingly we found that there are
pairs of shapes of the extra dimensions
that look completely different to a
geometers to a mathematician but are
completely identical from the standpoint
of physics now why is that interesting
well there's a lot of interesting things
there but the first application and this
application we actually wrote down in
our original paper with run and Plesser
but it was really Philip Ken Delos and
another team that put this into action
in a spectacular way we found that there
are certain mathematical questions about
these higher dimensional shapes that can
be ferociously difficult to answer on
one geometrical shape but if you make
use of its partner shape the mirror
partner that looks different but it has
the same physical properties many
questions that are horrific ly difficult
to answer on this shape when you
translate them into a question on the
mirror shape the question becomes easy
to solve in essence you have a
dictionary to go from difficult math
questions on this shape to easy math
questions on the mirror shape guaranteed
that the answer you get in the easy
setup will be the right answer for the
difficult setup and that's a powerful
tool obviously it's much easier to
answer easier questions and so Philip
can Delos and his crew were the first to
put this into action again we wrote down
the formula in our paper toward the end
of our paper but I never really thought
anyone would evaluate the formula I just
thought it was a cool observation to go
from hard to easy but Philip actually
put it into into practice and was able
to answer questions having to do with
the number of spheres that you can pack
in a certain way into these higher
dimensional shapes mathematicians had
answered very few of these questions you
can characterize the embedding of the
sphere into the shape of how many times
it winds around itself and people
mathematicians had answered the question
for the number of such spheres if
once twice but for three times the
mathematicians at that time had not been
able to crack that problem but in our
reformulations the easy question it
winds out that you can easily just write
a little computer program and spit out
the answer for a winding one two three
four up to whatever number you've got
patience for so I remember there's a
wonderful conference in 1991 in Berkeley
where a bunch of mathematicians came
bunch of us physicists string theorists
came to try to understand the math and
physics of mirror symmetries real
exciting time I remember I gave the
opening talk at that conference trying
to speak as best as I could at the time
and a language that would be acceptable
and relevant to both the physicists and
the mathematicians who generally speak
completely different languages you might
think we all speak mathematics but
honestly it's like when I went to
Scotland I met some people in Scotland
and I was like I could understand like
only I don't know 25% of what they're
saying we all speak English but man it
was tough and mathematicians and
physicists it's often the same kind of
thing we got a different dialect going
and the way we speak are mathematics so
trying to speak to both audiences is a
challenge but what happened at that
conference is some mathematicians came
along and they claimed that they had
finally cracked the problem of how many
times you can embed these spheres with
winding number three it turns out into a
particular six dimensional shape the
quintic hypersurface and complex
projective force based details don't
really matter but it's just a
complicated problem they had their
answer and the physicists had their
answer coming from our work in the work
of Ken Delos and the answers were
different and of course the
mathematicians thought the
mathematicians were right the physicists
thought the physicists were right and we
left that conference not knowing which
group was correct a few months later the
mathematicians send around an email
saying that they found a computer bug in
their code and when they fixed it lo and
behold the answer they got agreed with
what the physicists had been saying so
physics triumphed it was very exciting
time and again the mathematicians at
that time had difficulty going to
winding number 4
or five or six but we physicists it was
just a matter of hitting a button on a
computer and spitting out the answer so
there's a very powerful realization this
mirror symmetry for solving a collection
of interesting mathematical problems
anyway so you brought me back thirty
years now to some exciting times in the
early days of my own career so thank you
for doing that
okay let's see
so lion king lion king asks in the last
daily equation you said that entropy can
actually decrease if a system has a
small configuration like I did if you
remember I don't know if I did it I
think I did I did like 10 pennies I
think I did do that
I did 10 pennies and we found that if
you throw the pennies over and over
again using this computer code that
Danny Swift wrote for me World Science
Festival so that was sort of fun to have
that that you know if you allow the
computer to throw the pennies on the
floor on the table ten thousand times
certain number of times you see an
ordered outcome all heads are all tails
so entropy in some senses is going down
to metaphor of course but the metaphor
is that on occasion random processes can
yield ordered results it just happens on
occasion so the question of Lion King
asks is is it possible therefore for a
particle to travel back in time if
you're sort of in a small enough region
or a small enough number of particles
and I understand the intuition behind
the question lion king but I don't mean
to be
flippin but it's
a conflation of two ideas and this is
really important point if time were to
go backwards if you actually wind a film
backwards then indeed you can easily go
from disorder to order and I showed you
films of that in your daily question
you've seen them on your own you wind
the film backward and the shadow glass
does unshadowed the egg does on splatter
so it leads you to the intuition that
going to lower entropy is the same as
going back in time and that intuition is
wrong it's a natural intuition I get it
it really comes from thinking about as I
just mentioned winding films backward in
time but that's not the right way to
think about things
lowering entropy in the manner that I
was showing you is a forward directed
temporal process I was truly imagining
throwing those coins with time ticking
off in the ordinary temporal direction
and noticing on occasion holy smokes I
got all heads entropy went down nothing
to do with traveling backward in time
it's simply the fact that entropy and
its increase is a statistical likelihood
not an ironclad law and that's the point
that I was making there are these
ironclad provisional laws be they Newton
Einstein Schrodinger when we write down
those laws we're imagining that the laws
hold whether the right laws is a
separate question but if they were the
right laws they would hold they would
always hold they would never not hold
that's what we mean by the traditional
word law when applied to the universe
the second law of thermodynamics however
changes the meaning of law a little bit
we are not saying that there's an
ironclad rigid progression of entropic
increase we are saying that there's an
overwhelming likelihood of that
progression but on occasion entropy can
go down nothing to do with traveling
backward in time
okay um he's going by too fast I saw one
that I liked and it's gone Alpha Omega
spy asks how was your mother thank you
alpha mega spy that is so nice of you to
ask she's she's hanging in there she is
having a tough time but you know when
you're 92 going on 93 it is difficult it
is it is hard but she actually moved
from my house to my sister's house in
Massachusetts so she is convalescing
there at the moment at some point she
will be back here but thank you thank
you for asking okay so your question is
since particles do not care about time
why should particles care about natural
selection
why should particles seek to improve
themselves and there are two questions
in there they are highly related let me
take the second one first why should
particles seek to improve themselves so
Alpha Omega spy you're framing that in
language that I often used to you're
framing it in anthropomorphic language
you're framing it as though the
particles have a will have a
consciousness and you know my
perspective I don't think that they do
so when we talk about why particles seek
to improve themselves
I'd rather reframe it as why is the case
that over time particles can find
themselves in more refined more orderly
more organized configurations how in the
world would that come to be and the idea
here is that when molecules learn a
particular unusual trick when they
accomplish a systematic basis a
particular feat then they're subject to
a version of natural selection that
ordinarily we applied to living systems
but can equally well apply
to nonliving systems which is this so as
particles learn to replicate make copies
of themselves so imagine I've got a
collection of particles if that
collection of particles can make a
duplicate of itself and the duplicate
can make a duplicate of itself then we
find a natural means of taking stuff
from the disordered environment and
templating it into a repetitive
molecular order a repetitive molecular
structure a parent molecule has children
the children have children and the way
the children come to be is by the parent
grabbing raw materials and making a copy
of itself and therefore you can see that
those collections of particles that are
better at making copies for whatever
reason their electromagnetic structure
more readily pulls in the same
ingredients out of which they're made
their arrangement provides a natural
template that allows for a quick
replication whatever the reading
whatever the meaning and reason for that
the point is when particles get better
at making copies they dominate they
dominate the environment and if they
have a progeny a child that perhaps is
mutated maybe an interchange of two
particles in the arrangement if that
arrangement is better able to make
copies and have progeny then that
version will dominate the demographics
so you see a natural move toward more
organized structures that comes not
because animal species one is battling
species two in an arena of combat among
living systems but rather molecule one
is battling molecule two in a combat
that's taking place right down at the
level of particles and winners of that
combat can naturally dominate the world
now how does this relate to the fact
that the particles don't care about past
and future well again it's coming from
in essence the order of the Big Bang the
orderly structure of the Big Bang allows
for little pockets of order to form
those little pockets of order which are
in some sense residual order from the
Big Bang can make copies of themselves
and the molecular Darwinism that I was
just described can roll on forward if
the Big Bang was a highly disordered
state maximal disordered State from the
beginning if it was a collection of
black holes then we wouldn't have the
opportunity for the ordered structures
to ever get off the ground so the arrow
of time that I described in the last
episode in terms of the orderly Big Bang
second law of thermodynamics and drive
toward ever higher entropy is really an
arrow of time that would apply to all
processes for which we see a temporal
asymmetry including molecular Darwinism
so it's the same answer as an episode 32
ok gemstone replicators yes I'm
absolutely talking about replicators but
replicators down at the level of
collections of molecules would II live
at last hello Bryan Chad yes I give you
the thumb up woody you feel free to ask
a question if you'd like
Naveen Kumar makes a quantum-mechanical
prediction that the probability that I
will see this question is certainly zero
did you see this question or do you see
this andnothing Kumar I do not see your
question so your prediction is correct
the probability of my seeing it is zero
and I never ever saw it okay so what
else do we have here I am asked do we
understand space-time fully if not then
what are the gaps in our understanding
of space-time and I would say that
really is the central question for 21st
century fundamental physics we don't by
any means understand everything about
space-time at best we understand certain
qualities of space-time we learn those
qualities from mostly from Einstein's
special theory of relativity general
relativity we learn that time has this
weirdness it slows down in motion it
slows down in a gravitational potential
we know that space also contracts along
the direction of motion from special
relativity you know that space warps
from the general theory of relativity
but is that the end of the line no way
not at all if you were to ask me what do
we even mean by space and time I can
only give you a very rough answer an
answer that's really not much more
satisfying than the answer given by
Isaac Newton
you know Isaac Newton basically said
what is time didn't give a definition
Isaac Newton the per capilla just says
time flows equably he's just sort of
saying they're sort of equal intervals
and a repetitive pattern to the beat of
time but that doesn't give a definition
of time and when talking about space I
don't remember the exact language
someone can give it to us from the
Principia but when talking about space
Newton's description was again very much
focusing upon intuitive characteristics
of space but wasn't telling us what what
space actually is so the answer to your
question I am is we do not full
understand space-time and the gap is we
don't have a definition we're gonna have
a definition for space or a definition
for time some fundamental definition I
think of I said before my suspicion is
that the next leap and understanding
will be when we can identify ingredients
that make up space and time sort of
molecules and atoms of space and time
and loop quantum gravity is an approach
that believes that it has insight into
that question I'm less clear that those
insights are the right direction to go
but it's just to say that in loop
quantum gravity there's some thought
about what the atoms of space and time
might be in string theory in recent days
by days I mean last few years there's
been insight into relationship the
relationship between quantum
entanglement and in a sense the threads
of the space-time fabric and that's an
exciting development but these are all
tentative and so the next big
breakthrough will be moving from these
tentative ideas to ones that have a more
solid mathematical and ideally
observational footprint so that is vital
to have a full understanding of
space-time we are certainly far from
that at the moment all right let me just
look over from our Twitter side of
things I haven't been giving much
Twitter love in the last hour
okay Amanda says it seems like every
single event when analyzed specifically
enough can be seen as an unlikely event
and I agree I agree so why don't we take
that up with with the pennies because
that's an important point and I remember
when I was doing episode 32 in the back
of my mind Amanda I was wondering if I
had said enough to address that question
or not and I don't think I did so let me
point out
following when you throw pennies on a
table hundred pennies every outcome is
just as likely as every other outcome in
the sense of specifically delineating
the disposition of each and every coin
so imagine the coins are numbered one to
a hundred and every outcome if you want
to specifically delineate it requires me
to say coin one heads coin two heads
coin three tails coin four heads and
onward up to coin with label 100 let's
say it's heads every configuration
delineated at that level of specificity
is just as likely or just as unlikely as
every other because just as a single
coin has an equal probability of being
either heads or tails then if you got
two coins each of them has an equal
likelihood of being heads or tails
so whatever outcome you have is just as
likely just as unlikely as every other
now framing it that way you mean to say
well whoa what about the hole entropy
stuff what about the hole statement that
it's more likely to have 50 heads and 50
tails how do we square that with as
Amanda says every outcome being highly
unlikely it's one out of you know a
hundred octillion possibilities each and
every specific outcome what we do is we
group together certain outcomes and we
consider them part of the same group of
possibilities so when I talk about 50
heads and 50 tails I'm not worried about
whether the first coin is heads or tails
or whether the second coin is heads or
tails
I don't care all I care about is the
grand total number of coins that are
heads and the grand total number of
coins that are tails and there are an
enormous number of configurations in
that group
because again as I described in the
episode if you watched it you know I
don't care whether it's the first 50
coins that are heads and the second 50
better tails or if you know 35 of the
first 50 coin our heads and the other
heads come from 15 of the remaining 65
coins right so what only matters to me
is the grand total number of coins at
our heads and number of coins that who
tells not the specifics of which
particular coin is heads in which
particular coin is tails and by grouping
together the possible outcomes now I
have a different kind of comparison that
I can make I can send to my selves how
many outcomes are in that group versus
this group and if one group say has only
one member
like all heads one soul member every
single coin is heads whereas a group
that has a total of 50 heads and 50
tails has a hundred octillion members
because of the different rearrangements
of the individual coins that can fit the
bill of 50 heads and 50 tails so that's
the way we get the skewing of the odds
not by looking right down at the
specifics of any individual outcome but
rather by grouping the individual
outcomes according to a more macroscopic
quality in this case the net number of
heads and the net number of tails very
good question
Amanda um another one I'll just for the
heck of it since I'm over there on
Twitter
Zala Alex Boye 92 I have a question
regarding regarding that was a very New
York accent II so I'm gonna rewind the
film we'll just edit that out of de
finished you know we don't edit these at
all
so zal ex-boy 92 I have a question
regarding your illustration with the
change of trajectory of each and every
piece of the wineglass in order for the
glass to reassemble would gravity also
be required to be at an opposite for
this to happen wouldn't that break
Newton's second law and the answer is
you don't need gravity to be opposite so
if you actually go to episode of 32 I
spell this out mathematically I won't do
the math here but in Newton's second law
where the force is due to the force of
gravity so you have the force of gravity
as mass times acceleration when you look
at the acceleration D 2 X DT squared for
the original trajectory of the
splattering shattering glass versus D 2
X DT squared for the reverse motion you
wind up getting two minus signs in the
reverse motion because X of the reverse
motion is simply X of T of the reverse
motion is basically X of minus T of the
forward motion T goes to minus T every
time you take a derivative you get one
more minus sign you take two derivatives
minus times minus is plus so the reverse
run trajectory exactly satisfies
Newton's second law with the ordinary
everyday version of gravity not a
reverse version of gravity that's how it
works
so dang
jaws and says I don't agree with that
gravity matters I'm not sure what dange
is referring to maybe what I said I
don't think so
I was saying that gravity matters too
but you can't change his orientation or
maybe ding jaws was referring to
something in the chat maybe you guys are
having a side conversation that I missed
but any event Paul C asks hypervisor
green will you be putting episode number
24 up on the your daily channel again so
episode number 24 has become this kind
of enigma this legendary episode did it
ever really exists is the question that
we could ask now it's far less
mysterious than that it's not like the
what was it in The Maltese Falcon writes
the MacGuffin right it's the MacGuffin
episode no it really did exist as a and
I'm pretty honest with you guys not
pretty honest I'm completely honest with
you guys and I was rushing to do episode
24 or some of you may know and later in
the evening when I came back and looked
at it after it had been posted I
realized that I had made a little
mathematical mistake in one little
equation toward the end of the episode
and I probably should have just left it
up and done one of those I don't know
errata thingies that you can do in the
description I should have just done that
but I felt look I'll just fix it
tomorrow and tomorrow it turned into
episode 25 episode 26 and on it went so
I never got back to it so bottom line I
am gonna redo episode 24 maybe I hate to
say promises that I don't keep maybe
this weekend I'll find a little time to
redo episode 24 episode 24 was about
bohmian mechanics the browbone mechanics
I don't know maybe I could actually fold
episode 24 into a longer episode where I
talk about the various interpretations
of quantum mechanics maybe that's what I
should do so I could do the many-worlds
interpretation I could do the Fineman
approach to quantum mechanics I could do
Dubrow Boehm approach as was the core of
episode 24 and I could also do grw
theory which is another approach
to try to make full sense of quantum
mechanics that would make for a longer
episode but that's okay as you've
noticed I've been doing fewer episodes
but longer so maybe that's what I should
do interpretations of quantum mechanics
giving a little bit of the math of each
but maybe spending the bulk of the time
on the bomb debris theory yeah I don't
know I think I think I may do is kind of
like that I guess so so I think so al
baqarah Farooqi professor green wants
perfection in his work smiley face well
you know we try we try for perfection we
never achieve it but you know if you see
a an era it's a little hard it kind of
makes your heart hurt to leave that up
so that's why I had fixed it or didn't
fix that's why I took it down but we'll
fix him Joshua asks hi professor green
Joshua pasa can we set the geodesic
equation equal to the equations of
motion to derive the metric tensor for
that theory example given Maxwell's
equations could be quantized in metric
or not like gravity and it's a natural
question and you know anybody who
studied quantum mechanics and then
studies general relativity naturally
wonders whether the means by which we
quantize feels like Maxwell's field or
the strong nuclear or the weak nuclear
fields could those techniques be applied
to quantize the metric which is the
natural field in Einstein's theory of
gravity and the problem is when you try
to do that in the most straightforward
way the quantization yields nonsensical
results that's the problem we know how
to go from classical electromagnetic
theory to quantum mechanical
electromagnetic theory we know how to go
from classical strong and weak nuclear
force to quantum mechanical strong and
weak nuclear force and it all works all
holds together it agrees with the
observations spectacular when you apply
exactly the same template
gravitational theory of Einstein the
result that you get falls apart it's
nonsense
I mean do calculations and the most
straightforward approach to quantizing
gravity the answer you get is infinity
it's not like infinity should be
interpreted as a highly likely
probability it's infinite probability
it's definitely gonna happen
no and infinite probability is nonsense
a hundred percent probability we know
what that means 101 percent probability
no idea infinite probability nonsense
so that nonsense tells us that the
standard approach to quantizing a system
fails when it comes to gravity so what
have people done will the loop quantum
gravity people they found a way to
modify the standard quantization
approach they start with different
degrees of freedom not exactly the
metric something related to the metric
and this is somewhat controversial but
even the quantization approach that they
use some would say differs in important
ways from the standard quantization
approach that any undergraduate learns
in a quantum mechanics course string
theory takes a different tack string
theory says look let me just look at the
quantum mechanical motion of a vibrating
string not even thinking about gravity
and lo and behold when you look at the
quantum mechanical vibrations of a
string you find in there Einstein's
equations with modifications but in
certain contexts those modifications
would be small leaving us with
Einstein's equations so in loop quantum
gravity you basically start with
Einstein's equations and apply a
quantization procedure to go from the
classical theory to the quantum theory
in string theory you start with a string
a classical string you quantize it and
then you look at the kinds of forces
that that vibrating string can transmit
and within there you find the force of
gravity miraculous so it's a very
different approach
and which is the right one nobody as of
today can really say because neither of
these approaches is make contact in a
specific way with observations so koala
Jeet asks if strings are one-dimensional
then how do they vibrate in more than
one dimension and this is kind of fun
because this is my third note itself
that I should do an episode on string
theory I mean it would be kind of weird
to conclude your daily equation without
having any mention of string theory in
the more formal versions of the episodes
so just to refresh my own mind I don't
want I want to do on extra dimensions I
want to do one on string theory I want
to do impossible interpretation of
quantum mechanics so just to reiterate
to myself but back to your question
koala Jeet when we say that a string is
one-dimensional what we mean is that if
you were say an ant on that string did
only be one direction in which you could
walk you could go forward or backward
but there's only one independent
direction in which you could move but
that is intrinsic to the string itself
the string can be embedded in a higher
dimensional space and therefore the
motion of the string can make use of all
of the dimensions of the ambient
environment even though intrinsically
along the string itself there's only one
dimension in which that ant could move
so that's the difference you need to
distinguish between the intrinsic
dimension associated to an object which
is a dimension that spans the physical
extent of the object itself or the
string the span is only in one dimension
versus the ambient environment within
which that object is embedded and that
in bate and that ambe the vironment can
have more dimensions than the object
itself this happens all the time right
so you could have a flat piece of paper
embedded in a three-dimensional world of
course
the paper can ripple or flag right a
flag if it's infinitely thin it's got
two dimensions on the surface of the
flag but you put that flag up a flagpole
the flag is embedded in
three-dimensional space and then the
wind blows the flag is moving it's
vibrating in the three-dimensional
environment within which it is embedded
even though the flag itself only has two
dimensions intrinsically on its surface
that is the difference between these two
ideas okay
Siavash asks do you think AI will help
us understand the universe or will it
end us well it could easily be both I
think I may have mentioned in the last
episode but I do get my live sessions
and mine on live sessions and interviews
and other conversations that I have
sometimes mixed up so sorry if I'm
repeating myself but not everybody who
was at here now was at my other daily
equation say last time around so so
there
our AI researchers who came from the
world of physics who are incredibly
optimistic that we will use AI to solve
problems in physics that the patterns
that we need to recognize in the
external world and the mathematical
embodiment of those patterns we will
find AI systems that are better able to
spot those patterns and better able to
find the mathematical framework for
understanding them so hasn't happened
yet but when I listen to them speak I do
find it at least exciting and possibly
even convincing that's a really good
shot that AI will assist us in taking
the next step in perhaps the
not-too-distant future at the same time
that's not in contradiction with the
possibility that a Iong as you note in
your question could be the end of us I
mean a eyes goals need not align with
human goals I mean we certainly hope
that they will will try to program
things that that happens but the whole
point of of general artificial
intelligence is that there is a freedom
and flexibility in the kinds of ideas
and insights that run through the AI
system and who's to say that those ideas
insides goals will align with ours
moreover how do we know that they won't
be detrimental to us or ours and you
know they've been doomsday scenarios
that people have written down you know I
I think I saw I know where it was you've
probably seen it maybe was in New Yorker
cartoon or something and maybe wasn't a
cartoon I don't know but I saw this
image where you know he had some AI
system that was charged with making more
efficiently paperclips many cartoons he
probably seen it is you know this system
became so efficient at making paper
clips that basically extracted all
resources in the environment and filled
the earth with paper clips making it
uninhabitable
so it was very effective in cheating its
goal not so effective at achieving or
preserving our goal so I can certainly
imagine some catastrophe like that
happening obviously everybody will do
all they can to avoid that okay
so fabulous Ali asked how was your
experience on the set of The Big Bang
Theory non-scientific question sort of
fun to answer those sometimes it was
great it was great fun a long time ago
it was when it was when my next to last
book came out
yes that must have been 2011 oh my god
that long ago I guess and I was on a
book tour I'm the producers of the
creators of Big Bang Theory I don't know
they must have seen me on a book show or
something and they said how would you
like to do a book signing on national
television
on Big Bang Theory because their idea
was I'd be on the show and Sheldon and
it's a name Amy I always get mixed up
with the glasses the scientists
counterpart to Sheldon they would be at
your book signing and riffing in the
back of the bookstore that was the
conceit of the piece so I said to them
well let me think about whether I want
to do a book talk book signing on
national television on the number-one
rated television let me think about yes
I do want to do that and so I I went and
they had actually scripted it for me but
I said to them much better unscripted I
got the gist of where they wanted to go
with Heisenberg and uncertainty I said
look let me just let me just talk as I
would at a real book signing it'll be
more natural to be more real nerfect
fine so I just sort of did that I just
kind of talked at the front of the room
and Sheldon and if her name is Amy sorry
in the back I mean Maya is real know
what's around there Mayim I think so I'm
really I'm hearing I I need help when it
comes to names obviously but anyway so
they were in the back of the bookstore
set chatting away and making wisecracks
and jokes and I said I tell you so one
funny thing and then I'll move on back
to science because of scheduling we
didn't shoot that in front of a studio
audience and everything they do when it
was still in the air is shot in from a
studio audience and they only use things
that get a good laugh so after this day
of shooting they said to me we're gonna
show this segment tomorrow in front of
our live studio audience
and we'll record them and if they laugh
we'll keep it in the program but they
don't have we won't they oh goodness
gracious and thankfully they laughed
and so it was kept in the show which is
sort of fun and it's also a funny thing
from the perspective of you know I've
done I'm not that a lot of TV I've done
a fair bit of television you know I had
seven hours of documentaries on nova
elegant universe fabric of cosmos had a
90-minute documentary last year light
falls that I've mentioned here from time
to time and you know I've been on
interviewed in a lot of shows and so
forth over the years but none of that
has any impact compared to the impact of
90 seconds on Big Bang Theory number of
times that people ask me about that to
wharfs the number of times that people
ask me about elegant universe and fabric
of the cosmos I was just interesting the
power the power of popular culture all
right so moving on from there I saw some
kind of Columbia question but I can't it
went by too fast and I don't know where
it went
Erik Dobie says her name is blossom
blossom I don't actually watch Big Bang
Theory but blossom doesn't sound right
that's not who I have in mind awesome
who's blossom everyone's like oh it
doesn't have a blossom this time I know
what you're talking about
bill Hussam now I'm talking about she's
like a scientist in the show she a
scientist in real life she was a PhD in
in neuro science I believe by though I
can't remember it's it not Amy
someone tell me it's not her name in the
show consumer I think it is I think it
is I'm gonna assume that it is all right
so Abdullah TV says I have a theory and
I want to share it with you where can I
do that and how do I answer this
question and it is a good question to
address the number of theories that I'm
sent is far greater than the number of
theories that I can possibly look
through in a lifetime and it makes me
feel bad because people work very hard
on these ideas and they put their heart
and soul into some of the papers that
they write but it is simply impossible
for me to read through them
and I don't know what to say about that
you know I wish there was some way in
which all the interesting theory is that
people in the general public come up
with that they could be vetted in some
way maybe there's like some public
crowd-sourced website that we could
create in which the various theories
that people come up with could at least
be looked at I mean how sad is it to
work hard on something for years I've
gotten letters from people who've been
working on theories for 20 or 25 years
and no one's ever looked at these
theories and they send them to me off
his thick stacks and I look at them and
like oh my god it's gonna take me like
months to read through this and and I
don't have great confidence maybe I
don't want this to sound come off
sounding wrong but I don't have great
confidence that with our present state
of understanding that someone can sort
of leap to the frontier without having a
full grounding and all the physics that
came before I think many people have in
mind the image of Einstein in the Patent
Office the outsider but bear in mind
Einstein had a PhD in physics it wasn't
Einstein was just sort of some guy in
the patent office he was number one you
know kind of the most brilliant
scientific think of the world has ever
known
but put that to the side but he had
training yet training in math he had
training in physics he was therefore
well equipped especially at a time when
insights into certain key ideas had were
in their infancy but right now maybe
there are other ideas that are would be
in their infancy if we were to come up
with them but right now general tivity
is such a mature subject quantum
mechanics is a mature subject if you
want to push the boundary of generality
in quantum mechanics you've got to know
the state of the art in these subjects
and oftentimes what people are sending
me is something that's meant to push
quantum mechanics forward push general
relativity forward push unification
forward and I look at the papers and
the first paragraph I don't recognize
any of the things that we hold to be
true so that diminishes my confidence
that that theory is actually going to be
right so the answer to your question
abilities I don't know don't send it to
me I mean I don't mean to be mean but if
you send it to me I know I'm not gonna
read it so I don't want you to take the
trouble to send it to me but I wish I
you know in the best of all worlds you
send it to a journal and the journal
usually does make a quick assessment as
to whether that paper will go into the
review process so that's certainly an
option available to or posted I know
there are these various physics what are
they called chat rooms nots an old word
no there's a more modern murdered for it
bulletin boards no there's some word but
you know what I'm saying this place is
where people get together and discuss
physics maybe there's somebody there
would take a look but I apologize for
just not having the time to go through
everybody's here maybe somebody has the
answer and I'm missing it by not reading
it so that is the the risk that I take
okay
[Music]
what do we got here quantum jumps from
Austin Texas questions was your opinion
of Colombia move guess impact partway
through the question I have to keep
going Columbia Professor Peter White's
blog criticisms from not even wrong look
I've known Peter white since I was a
graduate student at Harvard yeah
yeah I went to give a talk at Stony
Brook in 1987 or so 1987 a long time ago
and Peter white was a postdoc there I
think and and we met and we had great
conversations and and I have you know I
think Peter is fundamentally a good
person and his heart is in the right
place of trying to bring ideas to the
public to try to minimize the hype that
sometimes does happen out there in the
world I mean I think sometimes it's
probably accused me of hype and that
actually strikes me in a deep place I
mean you gain a thick skin after a while
when you're out there in public and at
one level or another but I do all I can
really not to hype the public I really
do I'm very sensitive to qualifying
radical sounding statements when I talk
about the multiverse inevitably I say
these are hypothetical ideas that emerge
from the mathematics we don't know if
these ideas are correct from string
theory when I talk about it I inevitably
emphasize that we don't know if these
theories are correct because we haven't
connected them with observation
experiment so and I don't do that for
Peter I do it for me I do it because
it's part of my DNA that I want to be
out there speaking in a way that people
can trust I've turned down being on
major television interview programs
because the topic wasn't something I
felt I had any expertise in and I don't
want to be out there just spouting hot
air so so so I think it's important to
have someone policing if you will or
indicating when science is described
with unnecessary hyperbole unnecessary
hype if you will so so I get it and I
think that's fine it is good I do think
that Peter becomes unnecessarily
negative sometimes on ideas at the
forefront that we know are speculative
but nevertheless the mathematics is to
us so interesting and compelling that
we're willing to spend some time on it
so you know IIIi think what he's doing
is fine and people enjoyed and learned
something from his blog fantastic that
people get excited about science and it
reorients their thinking about what
aspects of recent work are worthy of
attention and which aren't fine but I do
think you need to listen to a spectrum
of people a spectrum of people that you
can trust and I hope that these sessions
have given you confidence that I'm one
of those trustworthy individuals who
really does put effort in to giving
answers that are sufficiently qualified
and sufficiently aware of the ways in
which other outlets may promote
unnecessarily certain far-out ideas that
really don't hold any water I mean
that's why for instance in the last one
of these live sessions I think I began
by talking about these headlines talking
about NASA finds evidence of a parallel
universe in which time elapses in the
reverse direction so I go my god really
again it's not that that isn't an idea
that was put forward by some scientists
but it's put forward as just one of a
collection of ideas many of which are
much less far-out and I think it's
unlikely that that far out explanation
will explain the data of the cosmic rays
being found in Antarctica so it's
unfortunate that those kind of
over-the-top suggestions which are put
forward by well-meaning scientists no
one's trying to mislead the public
that's not our goal
but in the hands of journalists
sometimes things get hyped in a way that
can be misleading
so anything that helps pull that back
ultimately I think is a it's a good
thing
okay
Danny Elma Cowie asks does the fact that
a scientific theory makes correct
predictions necessarily mean it is true
would it be accurate to say that
Newtonian physics is false but still
makes good predictions so to the first
question know what John I just sorry
about that I was not different my
microphone it is not the case that a
theory that has a history of making
highly accurate predictions is
necessarily true by any means right I
mean the theory can make accurate
predictions for experiments number one
through experiment a million and then on
experiment a million and one all of a
sudden you're like we have a crack in
the foundation the prediction of our
tested theory is disagreeing with
observation so all theories are
provisional right it's it's virtually
impossible to prove a theory all you can
ever do is increase your confidence in
the veracity the truthfulness the
relevance of that theory by testing it
in as many distinct contexts as you can
and so you know Newton's theory was
tested and a great many experiments
between the late 1600s and say the early
1900s and it worked but then Einstein
revealed that if you would have tested
Newton's theory in environments excuse
me where the speeds involved were
enormous it would not work and the
special theory of relativity supplanted
Newton's in that case but exactly as
you're saying Danny we still use
Newton's theory from a practical
standpoint if you want to calculate the
trajectory of a baseball flying from a
home plate to the outfield if you want
to calculate the trajectory of a rocket
going to the moon the Newtonian
description is so fantastically accurate
even if it has been superseded by the
quantum mechanical on the Einsteinian
view of the world those theories only
yield the mo
modest modification to the Newtonian
prediction in everyday situations and so
it is accurate to say that Newtonian
physics is in some sense false but still
makes good predictions in fact the way I
really like to say it is not exactly in
that language I like to say that
Newtonian physics is accurate in a
certain domain of the world when things
are not moving too quickly not near the
speed of light and when their masses are
not so large that the general theory of
relativity comes into the picture and so
if you want to enlarge the domain and
allow yourself to consider very high
speeds you better shift your theoretical
frame or to special relativity if you
want to enlarge that even more to allow
for aggregates of matter with the force
of gravity is really strong like black
holes you need to enhance enlarge your
framework to include the general theory
of relativity
so that's really the way science
progresses you have a theory that works
in some domain of reality and when you
want to expand that domain you need a
new theory I mean I want to expand that
domain you need a new theory still will
that ever stop will we ever have a
theory that just works in any domain
that you could possibly imagine maybe
that is string theory it could be maybe
not again we don't know if the theory is
right it hasn't made contact with
observation or experiments in a way that
allows us to adjudicate to distinguish
it in a manner where we can say that's
the theory that's describing the world
but that is the way physics progresses
okay let's see what else do we have here
actually what time is it oh it's a
quarter to five all right let's uh let's
just answer a few more questions today
so this is a question that seems to come
up on it on occasion maybe mr. castle
asked it last week I just I don't
remember things well enough but our
brain thoughts quantum processes so if
if if if mr. castle is asking this a
second time sorry for answering the
second time but at least I'll remember
for the third time so our brain thoughts
quantum processes of course their
quantum processes are they
due to the physical motion of the
particles are they due to the physical
development of the fields that are
existing within the architecture of the
brain absolutely I don't think that
consciousness and thoughts are anything
more than that are the mathematical
description of the forces at play for
the motion of particles and fields
regardless of it's a brain or a piece of
Swiss cheese are those laws quantum
mechanical of course they are so in that
sense I would say the answer is both yes
and no I don't think and I could be
wrong on this maybe future discoveries
will reveal some iconic quantum quality
that is the essence of consciousness
maybe but without that I would say that
a brain
processes internally that are
quantum-mechanical and a block of Swiss
cheese involves internal processes that
are quantum mechanical because
everything is quantum mechanical
the real question is is there some
iconic feature of quantum mechanics like
quantum entanglement or something like
that that's at the essence of physical
processes feeling the way they do to us
human beings feeling like grief or joy
or excitement or boredom as the case may
be and that's a question that I can't
answer my suspicion is that it's not
intrinsically quantum mechanical in some
fundamental way that distinguishes the
processes inside a brain from those of a
block of Swiss cheese but we will see
going forward if that perspective
continues to be viable
Maddy Ann says the best theories are
those we can quickly disprove they allow
us to learn and move on well yeah sure
in the best of all worlds and the best
of all worlds that excuse me and the
best of all worlds you're right Maddy if
every time we came up with an
interesting idea we could put it out
there and there was a machine that could
just test it disprove it say allowing us
to throw that away and move on that
would be the best and frankly we could
do that today with string theory if we
could
find any means of proving string theory
wrong I would be thrilled to bits and
I'm not joking when I say that
I'm not I'm not wedded to string theory
I've enjoyed working on it the math has
been incredibly exciting the math has
forced me to learn and expand my own
knowledge in what for me have been
gratifying ways I've been fortunate on
occasion to work on questions that were
ready to be cracked and was able to
contribute insights that people found
valuable that always makes you feel good
but I'm not wedded to any particular
theory
I am enamored with the possibility that
our generation will take us one step
closer to the truth
but there were many ways to take that
one step and as you point out Maddie one
way is to rule out theories that are
wrong because then it focuses your
attention hopefully on theories that
have this chance of being right but the
thing that you need to bear in mind
maddie is just because a theory is so
rich and complex and just because a
theory shows its true colors in domains
that are so small or so energetic that
they're beyond the reach of today's
equipment that shouldn't be taken as a
black mark against that theory no it
should be taken as a recognition of the
state of play and so because string
theory is difficult to test because it
does really reveal itself on a short
distance scales and high energies that
are beyond the reach of at least today's
equipment that's not a reason to say
that the theory is not worthwhile it's
simply a reason to recognize that it's
gonna be hard to come to a determination
of whether string theory is right and
wrong and notwithstanding people like
Peter Hoyt saying that string theory
qualifies for Wolfgang Pauli statement
not even wrong that to me feels very
counterproductive that kind of harping
from the sidelines feels very
counterproductive to me if it was me
harping from the sidelines on string
theory I'd rather be spending my time
trying to prove string theory wrong or
maybe even trying to prove it right
they're trying to contribute something
to the theory of trying to
take a different direction entirely and
say aha this is the way to quantum
gravity to simply say that a theory like
string theory is not even wrong it's so
unnecessarily negative it doesn't
accomplish anything because we who are
in the forefront of string theory itself
we readily say that this theory is hard
to test that we've yet to test it we'll
have yet to find direct observational
signature of the theory and we keep that
in the forefront of our thinking because
it keeps us on the lookout for indirect
ways that we might make contact between
strengths you're in observation so you
don't throw away a theory because it
takes a while for it to be tested that's
just I would say not a good means of
adjudicating between worthwhile theories
and theories that are not worthwhile
yeah so Jacob boon er said yes that is
paulie's phrase it absolutely is
paulie's phrase and you know Pauli was a
famously caustic physicist who had a
very sharp intellect sharp insight and
look if you take it in good fun if you
take not even wrong in good fun sure
yeah that's the way things are at the
moment we just don't know but I would
say that many theories in the stage of
development
I don't must say that every theory in
the stage of a develop if you're pushing
the frontier of understanding then you
are in a domain of not knowing whether
your theory is right or wrong and that
domain of development can stretch on for
decades if a theory sufficiently rich
and interesting that progress can be
made even though the theory is yet to be
tested so that is just the way things
are currently with string theory
yes a quantum jump says it's easy to
criticize is difficult to provide an
alternative and and I agree it's you
know that's a quicker way of saying what
I was saying just a moment to go if
you're gonna spend time an effort
criticizing a theory that's one way look
life is short life is short so you have
to ask yourself why would someone spend
their time criticizing a theory
spending their time trying to develop a
theory how much more exciting
how much more useful how much more
impactful to come up with new real ideas
that push the frontier of understanding
forward as opposed to standing on the
sidelines and saying II mm-hmm mmm
people make their own choices how to
spend their time I have an outlook I
like to think that I'm optimistic and
positive and certainly I spend my time
trying to push understanding forward
trying to bring understanding to a wide
audience that might allow others in the
group to push understanding forward and
to me it's just so much more exciting
your life is more exciting when you're
developing new ideas then when you're
sitting on the sidelines writing a blog
that's critical I don't know Oh to each
his own Paul see your book really is
good by the way thank you I appreciate
that
so si monster from last week was asking
what is gauge symmetry and I think I
promised oh goodness I promised I'd
answer what is gauge symmetry this week
and I don't feel unprepared good answer
to that
I know I've I promised for next week si
Mon so I must start it's this hard
question what is gates him and let me
just point out in the elegant universe
in Chapter it must be must be Chapter
seven I think I take
against image I tried to describe it in
general terms I'll go back and reread
what I wrote there 20 years ago it was
hard then it's only it's just as hard
now but let me just try to come up with
something that will satisfy you
si monster I apologize
okay what do we got well I haven't
looked over at the Twitter stuff in a
while let's see if we got here
let's see anything that strikes me some
Morgan wex hland wassailing asks if time
moves differently relative to math but I
think that means if mass itself can
impact the passage of time which it does
and the universe can have more mass here
or there at a different moment in time
could our perception of time be skewed
because of that and and the answer is
absolutely yes
if a civilization was born and existed
hovering in
ship at the edge of a black hole then
time as it elapses for those individuals
would be quite different from time as it
elapses for us so as we look at them we
would say their clocks are ticking off
much slower than our clocks in this
environment here on earth far away from
say that black hole and therefore their
perception of the universe would be
skewed in the temporal aspect by virtue
of the environment that they inhabit now
you might say then ok then like who's
right and I say well no one's really
right it's just that time is not
universal in the way that Newton
described it time is very much I hate to
say it sounds hackneyed that's in the
eye of the beholder in the sense that
time elapses at different rates for
different observers moving in different
ways and in the question of Morgan
experiencing different gravitational
fields so what makes us think that there
is any sense to a statement like the
universe is 13.8 billion years old what
does that mean if in different
environments the different amounts of
mass happen to be different motion
clocks tick off time at different rates
what do we mean by this seemingly
Universal cosmic statement about the age
of the universe and the answer to that
is this we live in a very special
universe we live in a universe which is
highly homogeneous and highly ossetra
isotropic not isotropic isotropic what I
mean by that is that let me just talk
loosely if you take a chunk of the
universe I don't know it's got to be
pretty big call it a hundred million
light-years across like a big chunk of
the universe every hundred million light
your tongue of the universe if you
average out over the mass
and if you average out over the
variations in temperature and so forth
if you average all those physical
qualities in that big chunk of the
universe then every hundred million
light years basically the same as every
other hundred million light years of the
universe
that's what I mean by homogeneous you
know the example that i that i use i
don't have my murky or gray water here
any longer
but you know you think of a cup of
coffee macroscopically it looks like a
uniform brown liquid let's say you've
got some milk in their uniform brown
liquid but you know if you dive into the
coffee you examine it on sufficiently
small scales it's not homogeneous on
small scales water over here milk
molecule over here sugar molecule over
here whatever it's got all sorts of
stuff all over the place it's only when
you average out over the entire cup of
coffee that it looks like uniform brown
sludge
similarly the universe certainly has
differences from place to place you
could be near a black hole or you could
be near a plan or you could be an
emptiness of space but if you average
all of the matter in a big enough chunk
and average out all the temperature make
big enough chunk then like the coffee
which looks like uniform brown sludge
the universe looks like uniform visible
properties and so if you use a clock
that is sensitive to those average
uniform properties in a given 100
million light years
the universe then all clocks of that
sort will have experienced more or less
the same physical environment and
conditions and evolution since the Big
Bang and that's the kind of clock that
we use when we talk about say a
universal notion like the age of the
universe so yes at the level of the
individual the matter in your
environment can absolutely skew your
temporal perspective on reality but we
in order to remove that very
individualistic quality of time when we
talk about cosmic time we're talking
about time measured on clocks sensitive
to the overall average features of the
physical universe and because the
universe is homogeneous those physical
features from place-to-place on average
are more or less the same therefore
clocks tick off time at more or less the
same rate important very important idea
very important question
all right what do we
five o'clock guys should we wrap it up
for today I'm starting to feel a little
bit exhausted and hungry myself but let
me just see if there are any other
questions that catch my eye before we do
that well Ian Richard grad well asks
maybe we perceive one linear hour of
time because we perceive only three
dimensions of space plus one of time
what would happen to our perception of
motion in trajectories and so on if we
were perceiving not just three but five
or more dimensions and if so Ian my
answer to that question is if we had
more space dimensions that we were
sensitive to I don't think that that
would give us much insight into the
arrow of time in a universe that has a
plurality of spatial dimensions like
three that doesn't give us any
particular insight into the hour of time
and so if we had one more dimension of
space or two more whatever I don't think
that the insight that we would gain from
picturing reality with those extra
dimensions would really help us at all
with the arrow of time others have
suggested something similar to what you
suggest in though which is even yet more
radical people have suggested maybe if
there are more than one dimension if
there is more than one dimension of time
if there are two dimensions of time
could there be some kind of symmetry
between past and future among these
multiple time dimensions and I don't
know people have tried to work out the
mathematics of a multi time universe it
seems as though in some versions you can
make some sense of the universe with two
dimensions of time it's never really
caught the physics world by storm
so nothing that I've ever seen has
provided me an aha moment
imagining a world with more than one
time dimension but who knows maybe in
the future that someone will develop
something in there that is insightful
but I've never I've never seen it at
least not as of today
so Andre Veltman says enjoying your
equations in the Netherlands daily
almost the only they were daily for a
while now I think it's really two or
three a week including this live session
I think it's probably the rhythm that we
will get into I think I will try to have
one for Monday and I think I will focus
on extra dimensions since a lot of
people are asking about that but Andre
Development asks how can a quantum bit
be of any use in spending my PhD in
electrical engineering I fail to
understand the details and well I don't
know if my answer is gonna help Andre
it's probably a description that you've
heard in one form or another but I'll
say it anyway just in case it is useful
to you or to anybody else listening we
all know that computers are based on an
architecture in which you have bits
binary digits that can be 0 or 1 plus or
minus whatever and that's a very
computationally useful way of breaking
down interesting questions they string
problems to frame them in terms that
only require us to process zeros or ones
that are moving through various
integrated circuits and the idea of a
quantum bit a qubit is to make use of
the fact that in quantum mechanics sure
you can have say spin up or spin down
that's like a 0 or a 1 but the quantum
mechanical wave function allows for the
weirdness of superposing and up and down
and you can't really think about that as
going off at a diagonal pictorially I
guess you can but it's really that we
can have a bit that simultaneously has a
little part of 0 and a little part of 1
simultaneously so in some sense if you
have a collection of qubits you're able
to do a whole variety of computation
simultaneously because those qubits can
embody both the 0 state and the 1 state
simultaneously and if you want to think
in what I would say is unnecessarily
speculative language but I think it's
useful and some of my colleagues do not
think this is speculative all they think
this is how quantum mechanics works but
if they use the so called many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
where when something is a mixture of up
and down and you go about engaging with
it interacting with it
according to this view of the world what
happens is there's a universe in which
it is up and a universe in which it is
down so these are not just hypothetical
blendings of mutually incompatible
realities it's an actual blending of
what we would normally in classical
language described as mutually
incompatible rounds how can we be up and
down simultaneously Agins up between a 0
and a 1 simultaneously but if you allow
for the quantum flexibility that allows
for a blending of up and down or 0 & 1
and if you interpret that in the
many-worlds interpretation then in some
sense when you're doing a calculation
with qubits you're making use of a huge
number of parallel universes to carry
out the calculations for Wednesday the
first bit is up and the second bit is up
or a different universe when the first
bit is up of the second but is down and
so on so using the quantum flexibility
of qubits in some sense their ability if
you think this way to access many worlds
simultaneously to use the computational
power of many universes to exponentially
speed up the duration for a given
calculation and that's what a quantum
computer promises us now again in the
spirit of not overhyping things although
some would say I'm about to under hype
quantum computing we know that there are
certain kinds of problems that are
amenable to algorithms that will
leverage the computational power of a
quantum computer but it's not like every
problem every question that we've ever
asked we know how to frame it in a way
that will truly make use of the power of
quantum computation and so it's not like
once we have quantum computers every
calculation speeds up exponentially
that's not guaranteed by any means the
only thing that we're certain about is
that those computations for which we
have already developed a quantum
algorithm for enacting that computation
then those will be sped up enormous Lee
but it could be the case that there are
a limited number of problems which
quantum computers will give you that
kick and maybe these are the most
important questions the ones the most
interest whatever so I'm not going to
value judge it but it's just to say that
don't immediately think that quantum
computation universally speeds up all
calculations exponentially that requires
finding the algorithms that will do that
well I've got an interesting do you see
this beam of light that's kind of going
through my head right now well kind of
dramatic what does that mean is that
like is that the alien ship the UFO
booming beaming in I should say on our
conversation trying to distract us I
think not
but there it is area 51 shining a ray of
light through the Catskill Mountains in
New York I like this one Alice Alice
vache yes sir have you any life advice
to offer us I've no doubt you much
wisdom to offer many thanks Alice well I
like to think that I've got some advice
I don't know if it's great wisdom but
you know I certainly to young scientists
I would say that the most important
thing in early stage is not to be at the
frontier of knowledge the most important
thing is not to spend three hours
talking with me about critical questions
at the forefront of string theory of
quantum mechanics the most important
thing is to learn the basics inside out
and sure you can spare three hours a
week to do something like this that's
really not what I was meaning as the
number of people listening dropped off
by 50% when I said then what I really
mean is that it's so important that you
learn the groundwork that one day you
will use if you go on in science because
nothing is more valuable than the
foundation upon which you can build
insights at the forefront but without
the foundation you will constantly find
yourself collapsing through
rotted floor boards unstable joists in
your understanding and it's best to get
that solid now at the learning stage not
try to fill that in later on I guess
vice vice number two I would give with
someone gave me a long time ago when you
come to do your PhD those are a little
more advanced I'd say don't view your
PhD is the best work of your life do
your PhD is an important stepping stone
to get you into the community of
researchers to get you out of school and
into the realm of full-time research
because there are many people who spend
an inordinate amount of time on their
PhD thinking that this is a defining
moment in their career it's not for most
people I mean for a few it is but for
most people their PhD is a necessary
step and route to the important
discovery that they will subsequently
make again there are exceptions to all
of this but I wouldn't allow an
unnecessary focus on achievement in your
PhD to slow you down get it done get the
PhD done get out into the world get a
postdoc job get into full-time research
focus your attention fully at that point
and don't unnecessary reading that PhD
six okay don't go more than six five
that's even better for better still
which I took got done two years two
years I just wanted to get it done
then I was out in the world doing stuff
so that would be one piece of us again
Alice I'm not sure with which side of
the academic or non-academic world you
approach that question from but at least
for the academic side of things those
are pieces of advice that I do feel
strongly about because a they helped me
and B I've seen them in action so many
times so I wants me to be the PhD
advisor to his or her or their PhD
thesis maybe gotta come to Columbia
though for that
where'd that question go I've got to
keep my fingers off of this thing
Randi lemundo says maybe great life
advice could be to find some talented
physics student and fund them well yeah
I mean funding it I mean you hat you end
it with lol but yeah I mean funding is a
big deal and it's become ever more
difficult you know the Department of
Energy for instance is cutting funding
in subsequent years with all that's
going on in the world and the funding
directly affects the number of students
that we can support the number of PhDs
that will be granted the number of new
able smart energetic physicists that
will enter the field so rather than
looking to government I think we may at
least the United States need to look to
philanthropy you know think about the
people who got trained in physics and
went on or mathematics and went on to
make billions of dollars you know great
example is Jim Simons as you may know
who incredibly successful in the
financial world who was a mathematics
professor before he made that move into
finance and now he's using his money to
do the most wonderful things supporting
postdoctoral fellows around the country
supporting for instance the World
Science Festival
the support that the Simons Foundation
Jim and Marilyn Simons provide also
providing support for faculty who are
going on leave to pursue research so
more the more people who would do that
the better off the field would be so
that is actually a vital part of from a
student perspective of what the future
will be like
so Joel Jarvan n asks hi Brian thanks
for the PhD advice you're welcome
gonna keep that in mind I hope you do
anyway could you elaborate on the
concept of speed and time what unit do
we use seconds per what yeah exactly so
what I really have in mind when I talk
about speed through time is the more
general idea of speed through space-time
and you may know again I'm not sure what
your background is but in the special
theory of relativity there is a natural
notion of speed through space-time
that comes from the for vector DX alpha
D tau and that for vector has length in
the Minkowski metric that is a magnitude
equal to 1 so when I taught him 1 is
where the speed of light is equal to 1
so when I talk about speed through
space-time being one in equations that's
really what I have in mind that the X
alpha D tau contracted with the X alpha
D tau with the Minkowski metric ada
alpha beta gives you a number whose
magnitude is equal to 1 what do I mean
in more general language the more
general language is that when you're
sitting still you
not moving through space but you do have
motion through time and you really can
think about that if you want as one
second per second you might say oh
that's kind of a silly idea but it's not
that silly when you think about it
because if you allow for that notion of
one second per second then when you
start getting up to move the rate of
ticking on your clock from my
perspective won't be one second per
second it'll be a number that's less
than one second per second because I see
your clock taking off time slowly so
what I'm really talking about is it's
the rate of your motion through time
compared to the rate of my motion
through time and when we are mutually at
rest then our passage through time is
the same 1 second per second but as you
get up and start to move through space
your speed through time slows in the
sense that the ticking of your clock is
less than one second per second as I'm
watching it go tick-tock and I'm
watching mine go tick-tock yours is
tick-tocking less frequently than mine
and that's the sense in which I can say
your speed through time is
seven seconds per second or 1/2 a second
per second your clock is only ticking
one half a second while mine is taking
off time one second so it's a very
concrete operational definition of your
speed through time it's the measure of
your passing through time compared to my
passes through time
okay so
eat m79 says my video and my sound are
not in sync anymore that is a
relativistic effect that happens when my
thoughts are near the speed of light
there is a disjuncture between my visual
and my audio when my thoughts are that
fast so I will try to slow my thoughts
down to try to bring synchronization
between my audio and my video I think I
may have accomplished it by now
but it could also be an internet
slowdown
okay so Joel gets back oh I see thank
you that clears things up a lot actually
great I'm glad in fact I'd love to hear
a little bit of feedback so I know
whether what I'm saying is getting
across at all oh it isn't sync for
Thomas and others good all right I'm
glad glad to hear that
all right maybe one or two more
questions and then we will call it a
Friday day out here which those of you I
mean how many of you is it like early
morning anybody it's like two o'clock in
the morning or something I know that
occurs for some of the regulars on this
yeah so koala g wants to know about our
general relativity course I don't know I
don't know I'd love to create a general
relativity course for world science U
but um it's so time-consuming to create
but I was thinking maybe this is a way
to think about it
quality maybe instead of putting out a
full general relativity course maybe I
just said as a goal to get out like the
first five modules of a general
relativity course put that out there and
then sometime later to the next modules
I don't know maybe maybe I can break one
course up into ten courses and do parts
one through part ten maybe that will be
less intimidating so it's almost 3:00
a.m. for our young it's 11 p.m. in
Sweden Joe where are you in Sweden I
have a warm spot for Sweden quantum
jumps can't wait for a talk on
dimensions what math
will you use oh well I'm not going to do
heavy-duty math I was thinking of just
doing an explanation of you know the
very basic distinction between 0 1 2 3 &
4 dimensions just using hypercubes
tesseracts as the operative example
that's sort of what I had in mind
and I also you know we have a VR project
I don't know how many of you have VR
equipment at home or have access to VR
equipment I don't know if you have that
I wouldn't mind hearing you just sort of
note it in the chat because we have this
VR lecture that we're developing we did
it once but now we're redeveloping it
even a more refined way in which if you
have VR equipment I think you need an
HCC vibe or something like that
using that you'll be able to join me in
a futuristic lecture theater floating in
outer space and I'll explain the basics
idea of string theory in that VR
environment and we will also be able to
build in virtual reality tesseract
hypercubes in in four or five or six
dimensions so if you have the equipment
that is the coolest way to experience
some of these ideas so I'll maybe in the
link for your daily equation when I talk
about the extra dimensions I'll have a
sign up place for those of you who
happen to have the equipment or access
to it so you can you can join in on that
and that's sort of the best way to
experience this stuff but I don't intend
to really do a higher dimensional romani
and curvature and things like that I
think it'll just take us too much into
the technical details of higher
dimensional spaces that won't be as
interesting to the people who typically
watch your daily equation morano's l
just asked one little question toward
the end here is there a god I don't know
I don't know Murat what do you think
all I can say is that if there is a God
God's been doing a pretty good job of
staying behind the scenes recently God's
been doing a pretty good job of allowing
lunacy to hold sway in America you know
it's the old problem of evil that the
philosopher is debated across the ages
if there is a good all loving God wise
or evil in the world and you know there
are many answers I'm sure you familiar
with them the idea that God creates some
life form and then allows that life form
autonomy and only by allowing that life
form autonomy can the good acts of that
life form really have meaning but the
capacity to do good comes with it the
capacity to do evil I don't know I'm not
really all convinced by this kind of
stuff but if you ask me my gut feeling
my gut feeling is sure there could be a
God behind it all set it all in motion
and all we're doing is figuring out
God's handiwork possible I don't see any
evidence for that whatsoever but that
doesn't mean it's not true on the other
hand if all that we physicists are doing
is working out the underlying laws and
there is no God
and what we're figuring out of the
mathematical patterns that govern
reality if that's what we're doing not
revealing God's handiwork but just
revealing the patterns that for some
reason or woven into the texture of
reality I'm quite excited to be part of
either of those journeys if what we're
doing is revealing the truth that God
put into place Wow
what a noble way to spend your time if
what we're doing is just working out the
patterns articulated in the human
language of mathematics
wow what a noble way to spend your time
so in a real concrete sense it doesn't
affect my day-to-day work whether there
is a God behind it all but for other
questions for many people questions of
value and meaning are intimately
connected with the potential existence
of a god from my own perspective I like
to flip it around a little bit I don't I
don't view the journey toward those
insights that for some people not all
but for some people that religion helps
reveal I consider those journeys not to
understand the external reality but
rather to understand the internal
reality of conscious awareness the
internal subjectivity of what it means
to be a life form a human being living
in this universe and that journey to
understand our own conscious awareness
to try to understand why we behave the
way that we do why we have the feelings
that we do to try to under the
understand the truths that are not
amenable to description and ordinary
language the kinds of truths that would
be diminished by trying to describe them
in ordinary language the truths that we
can sense and feel but we can't quite
articulate for some people that's what
the spiritual journey is all about and I
consider that to be a valuable journey I
consider that to be a complimentary
journey to the one that we physicists
try to reveal in the equations
describing an object of world
so that doesn't necessarily mean that
the journeys toward a god in any
conventional sense one of the dominant
world religions rather I see it as a
spiritual journey that recognizes that
there's more to the world than the
objective truths that are available to
everybody who studies the universe with
adequate intensity the subjective truths
that are only true for you or only true
for me those are not available to
everybody they're only available to the
individual and you can do your best to
explain them if you want if you're
motivated but ultimately they are deeply
personal qualities of your peculiar
combination of particles that defines
you as an individual being in this
reality and I think that the journey to
understand yourself in that way is a
valuable one and I consider that
spiritual some would say it's religious
but clearly the language and the
approach that I'm describing is not
fully aligned with any of the more
conventional world religions so its
oblique to perhaps what you had in mind
more at when you're asked is here at God
but nevertheless I hope that gives a
sense of how I
organize my own thinking about the
qualities of the world that matter
all right
so rubber jjigae Nome Nome says I think
it is a bad idea to call subjective
stuff quote someone's truth plenty of
good names for those things and I'd be
interested to know what you mean by that
rubber genome rubber genome because I
really am using that language with
forethought and it for me at least it
does capture in language as best as I'm
able to the ideas that I'm trying to
communicate which is there really are to
me qualities of the world qualities of
being alive that are deeply personal and
deeply iconic it's not that others don't
have similar feelings that's not what
I'm trying to say but they're not things
that I need to be verified through
observation or experiment they're not
things that I need to have a
mathematical equation in order to feel
that I've grasped you know when I'm
listening to a great piece of music you
know the Goldberg Variations Goldberg
Variations number 25 Wow
when you listen to listen to Glenn Gould
version of Goldberg Variations number 25
and the feelings that that can inspire I
don't know the words to describe them
but I can't help but describe them with
the word truth and I can't help but put
the word subjective in front of it
because you know it's a truth that's
emerging not from
some objective analysis of say the
electrons magnetic moment but rather a
subjective feeling that I don't even
care if I'm able to describe to the
object of world with any degree of
accuracy I know it's true I can feel it
it's a quality of the world that I
deeply value and therefore I tend to use
the language subjective truth to
describe it so if you have other
language that you think is better and
works better for you by all means use it
really I mean that but for me I have
found that notion of subjective truth to
be a useful and now I do agree that you
can take these notions and twist them in
dangerous ways you can start to twist
them and talk about alternative facts
you say well that's a fact that's true
for me but not for you
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
not talking about qualities of the world
that are accessible to all of us I'm not
talking about what happened in a
conversation between one leader and
another I'm not talking about
whether
the climate is undergoing certain
transformations I'm not talking about
the objective qualities of the world
that in principle are available to all
of us if we are privy to the information
and if we are privy to the equipment
necessary to become aware of that
information I'm talking about the deeply
personal qualities of existence and
there is a pretty clear way to have a
demarcation between my use of the word
subjective truth and the ridiculous the
dangerous the unjustifiable the devious
use of terms like
alternate facts
no connection
whatsoever
yeah so the Chopin
March I agree there there there there
are many there are many ways to achieve
the kind of experience that I was
referring to rubber genome by the way I
gotten to strength through research with
the elegant universe thank you so much
for that so so yes no I wasn't I was in
China I hope I hope my little diatribe
here was not taken as a critique of what
you said at all I'm just giving you my
honest reaction to to the comments that
I'm reading here so Brad Dibble hi
professor Greene Louisville Slugger here
by which I suspect Brad is reminding me
that he has spoken of the Louisville
Slugger that I see currently in the
corner of this room how do physicists
know that the CMB started 380,000 years
after the Big Bang and the answer to
that is we have an understanding of how
the universe changed in time coming from
the equations of the general theory of
relativity we have an understanding of
the temperatures at which say electrons
will be so juiced by the ambient
temperature that they will not stick in
orbit around protons and it's when
electrons are able to stick in orbit
around protons that the material in the
universe becomes overall neutral
positive proton negative electron high
enough temperatures they're all floating
this way and that and when they're
floating this way and that light can't
penetrate why light is affected by the
electromagnetic force light is the
carrier of the electromagnetic force if
you've got charged particles around the
light gets buffeted to and fro and it
can't get through the plasma of
particles it becomes opaque only when
the protons grab the electrons making
neutral atoms can light
freely travel because now it's not
encountering the charged particles of
the plasma and we can work out how long
it takes for the universe to cool down
after the Big Bang for that so-called
recombination that putting together of
electrons and protons into neutral atoms
how long it will take and it will take
about 380,000 years for the universe to
settle down into a state where there
isn't a plasma of charged particles that
prevents the Cosmic Microwave Background
photons from traversing through space
unimpeded and that's where that number
comes from the other thing it comes from
is we can measure the degree of redshift
this came up early the degree of
redshift of photons and the degree of
the redshift of the photons gives us an
understanding of how long they've been
traveling together their cosmological
theories we can figure out how long
they've been traveling so that's where
that's where these numbers come from
so so ban so van so I don't think I'm
pronouncing that's right
so ban Rabbani last night I was watching
the episode you talked about the big
bang with dr. Tyson Neil Tyson on a star
talk show
absolutely fantastic thank you it was
amazed by the effort you put on string
theory all these oh okay that was just a
compliment not a question so thank you
so van I appreciate that
alright anything left to go any time
left
oh it's 5:30 so I don't know maybe we'll
them go for a few more minutes and then
wrap it up
okay well life and thought always exist
in the universe and it's cyclical in the
universe cyclical infinite well look if
the universe is cyclic expands and
contracts expands and contracts then our
universe is one episode in that sequence
and we have no idea whether life is a
natural outcome or a rare outcome and
therefore we have no idea whether life
will persist in the other cycles we just
don't know it's possible you know this
interesting work by jeremy england and
clappers beck Jeremy's coming out with a
book I'm meant to read it I've got to
read it really soon I want to give it a
it seems like a wonderful book so I want
to endorse it but I have to finish the
reading of it but Jeremy has these these
theories or a theory about life that
perhaps suggests that life might be a
fairly commonplace outcome of a hot star
raining down energy on a planet with
certain kinds of complex molecules and
you know if that's the case then maybe
life is commonplace and maybe indeed
life would be commonplace across all the
cycles in a cyclical cosmology but
there's nothing that establishes that as
an absolute truth so who knows maybe
that a cyclical universe maybe none of
the cycles except ours would support
life possible
don't know all right I'm gonna look for
a final question here and then wrap it
up all right I'm gonna end with short
cut
well psychedelics help us understand
consciousness
I think the answer to that is yes
and I'll tell you why you know one of
the most difficult things about
understanding consciousness is that we
try to understand consciousness with
consciousness we try to understand the
phenomenon by experiencing the phenomena
and that's not to say that researchers
careful researchers don't do everything
that they can to try to find objective
signatures of conscious awareness and
they look for correlations within the
physical properties of the brain the
physical processes in the brain they try
to line up certain kinds of qualities of
conscious experience with certain kind
of physical processes taking place and
it brings all this is great but you
can't help but wonder
about the possibility that if our
experience of consciousness is much
broader then it would be in the absence
of psychedelic experiences that that
can't help but broaden our perspective
on what consciousness is and what it's
capable of and what the phenomenon that
we're trying to explain what they
actually are and look this is a slippery
slope and a dangerous path to walk down
because not all psychedelic experiences
are benign not all of them are safe so
these kinds of explorations need to be
done in a safe way and is it controlled
away as possible but I am of the opinion
that broadly broadening our
understanding of the spectrum of
conscious experience can only help to
provide insight into a consciousness
actually is so who knows and again I
don't do research on consciousness nor
do I take psychedelics so I'm one step
removed on both of these fronts so it'd
be better for to ask that question from
somebody in the trenches who's actually
working on consciousness from a
scientific perspective and there many
researchers who do that but speaking as
someone who knows what it takes to make
progress on difficult scientific
questions I will say that we've always
found that when you can broaden your
perspective on that issue on that
question see it from a variety of
different angles bring an unexpected
links to other qualities of the world
that can sometimes be what it takes to
seed a breakthrough and
experiences can be one pathway toward
that kind of broadening of perspective
it cannot be done in a way that is
irresponsible it cannot be done in a way
that isn't carefully thought-out and
controlled but if that is the context in
which it takes place then yes I do think
psychedelics potentially have something
to offer in our understanding of
consciousness all right with that I will
wrap it up for today as I said I'll try
to do a your daily equation for for
Monday maybe on extra dimensions we'll
certainly meet again next Friday next
Friday I think I'm also going to do one
of these reddit public access network
things from 2 to 3 o'clock one hour
before this and that may impact how long
I go next week on your day of the
equation so if you want to start an hour
earlier you can absolutely do that our
pan just look it up and other than that
I will see you metaphorically on Monday
I believe and in this live session one
week from today all right thanks for all
the questions thanks for hanging out
have a good weekend see you then
you